so let's get into this um Dylan yeah
let's get into this story so earlier
today some documents were released that
were text messages from the two supposed
victims that came out one was the
moldovan that we've already covered in
the American and if you look over those
text messages you could see how not only
did they plot to frame the tape Brothers
they rehearsed it going over what to say
how to look how to cry and how to play
dumb they even made a joke two days
before the raid happened how their
performance deserved an Oscar that they
were going to get a Netflix documentary
out of all of this same things such as
and I quote such a great actress to
which the other girl said I practiced
quote unquote their performance was so
good that even their own parents called
the US Embassy and were freaking out and
the girls got upset with their parents
because they almost messed up the show
and they admitted that they were
actually kidnapped that the tape
Brothers said that they could leave
whenever they wanted so it seems that
while the mainstream media and the
police are saying that the tape Brothers
used the Loverboy method actually what
happened was these girls girls acted as
if they were in love with the tape
brother so that they could secretly milk
it and get as much money and influence
and have people talking about them as
they could so my question is this how
long have the police had access to these
documents I mean they were already
wiretapping the tape Brothers for the
past 10 months for 10 months the police
have tried to bury the CCTV footage that
proves the tape Brothers innocence and
yes I know what you're thinking these
text messages have already been verified
they're 100 true but hey I don't want to
just tell you I want you to actually go
and see it for yourself check out the
article come to your own conclusion use
your own two eyes and use your own mind
the Tate Brothers have been framed
there's a news story unfolding that the
mainstream media seems to be silent on
it's on the what I call the two
underwear wear wearing in public uh I
don't know if they're strippers uh the
U.S and the UK girl evidence is coming
out that they plotted and planned a
setup they literally acted as if they
were in love with the the brothers they
what I would say they they applied the
this lover girl method the text text
showing them plotting to frame the
brothers uh you also talk about how they
schemed on what to say the lot how to
lie how to cry you know they bragged
about is it true winning an Oscar
performance to get on Netflix
uh and the question is uh will the
Romanian prosecutors uh prosecute what
we say these two shaitans yeah they are
shaitan for sure I mean
we'll see brother I mean they're legally
I can't talk about certain things are
going on but obviously anything I've put
out publicly I can I can go into that in
great detail but we've got two young men
Andrew Kate trusted Tate for 10 months
they were wiretapped like all their
phone calls or text messages emails they
took all their computers they were
analyzing that they got new computers
but they were wiretapped for 10 months
the I think it's called dcot basically
to simplify for the viewers that's the
police the police Romania
grab the CCT uh footage which clearly
showed that these women were not victims
you could see them going out getting in
cars leaving uh going getting pizza
there's some of it's still out there but
essentially they tried to destroy it get
rid of it they won't include it in any
of the Court like whenever you're
sitting down the court they won't
include it as evidence not it's that's
not we don't need that that's that's not
useful but then add to that now we've
got these text messages that have come
out and they've been verified because I
was I was like uh maybe maybe that's
just like a coincidence or something but
we've had it verified it's 100 real of
them literally plotting leading up to
two days before the raid exactly what
they were going to do step by step by
step and like they were joking around
how they were going to be uh oh you're
such a great actress we're going to get
a an Oscar we're gonna do this we're
gonna do that and then whenever the
police raided the house the first time
the the their parents like called
they're oh my God freaking out like oh
are you okay they're oh don't worry
about it Mom we're good please don't
like cause any trouble like as the
parents are trying to call the Embassy
the U.S embassy figure out what was
going on and they jokingly are saying oh
it's it's all good mom don't worry about
it we're good uh they told us we could
leave at any time and all this stuff is
there as clear as day and for me it's
Insanity we do live in the word world of
shaitan obviously so there's nah the
truth we don't we don't need that so the
media the mains for media has this
narrative they're trying to push the
human trafficking uh but then the
evidence because always the truth
prevails the truth prevailed and it's
like uh actually that wasn't true okay
let's now let's try to go over here but
the thing that frustrates me the most
about this whole thing I mean obviously
I am biased because he's a good friend
of mine but secondly there's all this
evidence out there that proves the
complete opposite and now these text
messages it literally proves that the
lover boy method happened but it was
actually lover girl they're sitting
there acting like they're serious and
all that oh okay I will come out I I
think I think you might be the one like
talking to them convincing them that
they actually cared about them they come
out there they're staying at the house
living their best life posting their
their shaitan her very Haram Tick Tock
videos and just enjoying life
and then they're actually plotting the
whole time and then and I posted this I
want to say in part three or part four
these two young women and there's lots
of evidence that shows that many girls
that were around the tape brothers were
offered money ranging from thirty
thousand to fifty thousand dollars some
cases even a hundred thousand dollars to
try to frame them but I find it funny
that these two young women and I've got
the the picture on my phone actually
these two young women went on this fret
for Vera holiday which is a pretty
expensive thing flexing this really nice
watch driving a really nice car after
this they were just kidnapped and
liberated
like literally like a week or two after
the rate happened they were partying in
the French Rivera together the two girls
that were the two victims and one of
them tried to claim the UK girl the
moldovan she claimed that she was this
poor girl that he manipulated her and
all that well guess what actually that's
completely false she lived in the UK she
was a stripper she had good money and if
you and I can't go into certain details
uh but the brothers were actually
helping uh rehabilitate her from a
certain very Haram thing uh they were
trying to help her out and then when
they realized that she had bad
intentions they that was when they
started distancing themselves uh and
then the the American
literally land with the the ChatON in
America
she was got mad because she tried to get
a house out of the whole interaction she
wanted him to pick by her house help
make her Tick Tock famous and all this
other stuff and he said no and actually
something I found today a follower of
mine on Twitter sent it over to me
she's this girl the American and I could
say the name out loud so it's not
doxinger it's already out there her
name's Emma Emma has a long history of
this type of stuff all the way dating
back to whenever she was 15 years old
she got mad at her mom and tried to she
just disappeared
and this is literally a recurring theme
for this girl trying to act like people
are doing stuff to or trying to like
false rape things falsely oh I've been
kidnapped but it's just because she's
trying to get attention
so this pattern's continued up to these
two young women beating and plotting to
frame the Tate Brothers I don't know
their intentions behind out outside of
they just wanted attention because
obviously they wanted to have a
documentary they wanted to have their
own Netflix show they wanted the Oscar
they own all these things
uh but it's Insanity to me because if
you're wiretapping somebody for 10
months you there's no reality where you
didn't see those text messages because
they wiretapped anybody close to them
that's why whenever the tape Brothers
the second time
Andrew got arrested Tristan got arrested
and some other people around him got
arrested which all of them also had kids
funnily enough but oh it's okay or let's
just try to push the certain narrative
so at this point like if in my opinion
and I'm not a journalist I'm not a
lawyer I'm just a regular dude out here
on my path
at this point with these text messages
that this does not completely okay
let's we obviously don't have anything
these text messages completely disprove
everything that we've tried to build
this case over if that doesn't happen
like I'm gonna be I'm gonna be angry
because that's Insanity like if clear as
day these two victims were very
obviously they were plotting they were
rehearsing they're oh actually uh maybe
here's how you can actually look like
you're crying oh no don't say that you
need to play dumb okay yeah let's dress
up like this oh okay I'm gonna say this
and if they ask this question I want you
to say this as well they're plotting
everything and there's no way the police
didn't know it so I mean that that's my
bid on that I could talk for hours about
this I want people to understand so we
have the first thing that was a red
light where you imagine now someone
comes into your house you got cameras
all over and they come in and they steal
your stuff and now you can clearly
identify
who did it you can clear identify what
they stole but now the prosecution
doesn't want to use this case for use
this uh footage for example Now flip
that if if we're understanding this
correctly you have footage of everything
that's going on in the house but the
prosecutor now is not using this they're
not allowing this into evidence they
won't even touch it okay I think they've
used aspects of it but like for the most
part don't even touch it and then this
is a career this is not you making this
stuff up this is I mean anyone can look
into this this is yeah a brother Solomon
I forgot the last name like he he does
amazing yes yes I had him on a program
my brother
yes hear me like talk or whatever go
check his Twitter out he does very very
good work I've actually learned some
stuff from him just seeing his stuff on
Twitter so I was like oh wow didn't know
that so yeah I mean this stuff's
verifiable and example whatever this
whole case was beginning
they wouldn't even give the evidence to
the the law the original lawyer that we
had which we still have would even give
it to them until literally like 15 to 30
minutes before and it was a stack of
like 17 000 yeah 17 000 uh yeah 17 000
documents imagine 17 000 documents
you're given right before how can you
build a defense to that yeah it's little
things like this like I started to think
you know what
there is Justice and in Romania I'm sure
they're gonna they'll get to the bottom
of this but then after what happened
yesterday and I saw those text messages
I was like okay I I I think I see the
game they're playing they're trying to
embarrass them and they've taken the the
property over there we still have
absolutely they haven't taken everything
but in Romania specifically uh they've
tried to take their cars they're trying
to humiliate them they're they've even
taken hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of crypto I mean and all this
stuff is documented so I'm not just
putting out inside or not all this
stuff's documented and they brag about
it the Romanian media and the government
brag about it like look what we can do
so it's not going to look good for many
many years like Romania is known for
being very corrupt but they're initially
I think they're trying to show oh we're
not corrupt this is literally proving
that they're corrupt and if you're a
foreigner why even waste time in a
country like Romania that's very corrupt
and is going to Target you because you
have money and believe something like
these two young women that are
completely fabricated you know it's
fabricated you have all this evidence
that's fabricated but you continue
keeping these two men and locked up in a
jail cell and you're like not allowing
them to have guests like I've tried to
go other like family members of theirs
I've tried to go
won't allow it there's little things
like this brother it's it's really
annoying it's really annoying so we have
that one red light here with the camera
footage number two is I want people to
imagine if you got arrested and now
you're like okay who's uh speaking out
against who are the people now that are
coming up to say I did something who are
the victims and now they got X and Y uh
on the witness sheet and you're like
hold on you know you're saying I didn't
do anything but not just that now those
victims that the cops came out they're
also protesting saying that we shouldn't
be on that list it's yeah we're not
victims we also have that okay piece of
evidence there you also have that that's
a red light and then now we have that
you have other things but now we have
this coming out that this is the the
what's the the messages the text
messages
going in detail on the conversations of
these two strippers and I I also heard
that uh one of them are which one was
doing prostitution
was there something there with that yeah
to my knowledge that was the the girl
from the UK and then the other girl is
like a stripper influencer yeah so you
got a stripper and a prostitute now
coming together to set up a frame job
and all the details are there and
they're bragging out how they can win an
Oscar trying to get a Netflix
documentary going
Romania what are you doing what's up and
I think we need look Dylan I think we
need some Brave congressmen to step up
to go ahead this is a U.S citizen you
know you can like him or you like him
not you know what I mean but at the end
of the day if you're out for justice you
know about certain principles you've got
some Integrity now you should have some
U.S congressman step up to go ahead and
Advocate you know based on all of this
evidence now that's com that's that's uh
for them not against them because in
Romania what we come to know is that the
prosecutor has is trying to get evidence
and now if the defense if you come up
with evidence that can exonerate them
they won't even use that
that's how their legal system that's how
they're set up I'm hearing this yeah
that's crazy
I won't even look at it brother and we
actually we have an American lawyer that
went over there and we part of the team
was trying to get in wouldn't even allow
it so it's like little little things
like this it's going to take and the sad
part of this world now is we we like to
be divisive a lot of people create their
entire perception of reality based off
headlines so they oh okay Andrew's uh
Andrew's this this and this so any he's
just bad but
then if you just turn and look at the
truth it's very obvious that everything
that the media and everybody else is
saying it's just false so hopefully
we'll see God willing we're inshallah
inshallah yeah we will have somebody
from America that's prominent come
forward and actually start talking I've
seen he's not a politician but like
people like Tucker Carlson's mother like
Americans I guess with a an audience
have come out and been supportive but
it's good it's literally going to take
like some kind of American politician
that would make me gain a lot of respect
I had to come out there because these
are two American citizens being held
with zero evidence having their
properties stolen in a foreign country I
mean that sounds like something that the
U.S should actually care about yeah this
sets the president's for some what
someone else in American U.S citizen
comes up you know Americans U.S citizen
has rights now we need to go ahead and
protect these rights and you can see
they're being violated like him or like
him not if if it if he did a crime if he
did something wrong okay show the
evidence take care of what you got to
take care of but now you have all this
stuff coming out you got two stripper
and a prostitute trying to women any I
mean award an Oscar I mean come on is
that right now bragging about it I mean
come on enough is enough so action items
Dylan I mean we can give the people
start calling your uh what do you think
they can start calling some of their
local congressmen put some pressure put
some pressure on these politicians and
let's see if someone who has some
cojones as they call it you know some
Brave politician Congressman whoever can
come up and start to go ahead and
Advocate on on the U.S citizens behalf
what do you think yeah 100 brother I'd
say do that I mean social media has been
powerful but if we truly truly are in
alignment with the truth in alignment
with God and like we see that this is
clearly not a good thing like we can see
the evidence clear as day and use your
own two eyes use your own mind I'm not
telling you what to do what to believe
go go look at it yourself but the
evidence is clear that they've been
framed call your local Congressman call
even call the Embassy call the Embassy
try like just beef them beef them and
just put it out there because unless we
actually do something we were talking
about earlier you can't just talk about
it you've got to actually show it
if you actually if you actually care
about the truth you need to go out there
and show it in the real world you need
to go out there call your like you're
saying your local congressman
Embassy I mean literally anything
anything and everybody and we'll see if
anybody actually has the kahunas I think
you said to like stand up and actually
be like okay maybe I don't like this guy
maybe I don't like the lifestyle but I I
Stand For America I stand for truth and
these are two obviously innocent young
young men so I'm going to stand up and
I'm going to do something about it so
we'll see we'll see
uh Dylan thank you very much uh for
coming on and uh we'll be in touch get
uh let's uh keep uh in contact and we
can help you along your journey and all
along your way and hopefully next time
well we speak our uh Andrew tank
Christian uh Tristan Tate will be out of
this uh dungeon and um they'll be out uh
as I believe they're being held hostage
now so in Charlotte they'll be set free
thank you brother for having me thank
you very much assalamu alaikum peace be
with you thank you too I cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you are not
yet Muslim and you tune in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedineshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide brothers
and sisters we've all had love